à
[Musique]
chanter pour calmer l'angoissé pour se
rapprocher peut-être aussi un peu avec
les voisins c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement en italie
vous savez tout le pays était en
quarantaine 60 millions d'italiens en
raison du coroner virus et le bilan
chaque jour s'alourdit d'ailleurs la
journée d'hier a été la plus meurtrière
en italie avec 250 des sièges retrouver
rome
notre collaboratrice ariel d'humour
bonjour ariel quel est l'état de la
situation ce matin en italie et bien
écoutez pour le moment où on attend on
attend la fin du week-end parce que la
semaine dernière lorsque les mesures
d'isolement ont été renforcées notamment
dans tout le nord de l'italie puisque
c'est là que ça a commencé il y a
environ vingt mille résidents qui ont
essayé de s'enfuir et qui sont partis
dans toutes les régions du sud
alors disons que ça fait quand même
entre guillemets des potentiels risques
de contamination et le gouvernement est
quand même très très inquiet parce que
vous savez il ya un énorme problème en
italie au niveau de la santé publique
dire qu'il ya une santé qui est
extrêmement défaillante il n'y a pas
suffisamment médecins les structures
hospitalières et notamment les
départements de soins intensifs sont
insuffisants et dans tout le sud de la
péninsule la situation est encore plus
délicate
alors s'il y avait véritablement une
augmentation du nombre de cas est une
propagation dans tout le mezzogiorno loi
on irait véritablement vers un scénario
catastrophe
l'italie qui est devenue le deuxième
pays où il ya le plus de cas après après
la chine n'a quand on regarde l'état
international de lakovic 19 et ç'a
dépassé vous venez de la mentionner la
capacité du réseau hospitalier de
pouvoir soigner tout le monde
oui tout à fait au point que
malheureusement il ya des choix qui sont
faits c'est à dire que si vous avez deux
personnes qui vont entrer en soins
intensifs
eh bien on fera passer celle qui a le
plus de chances de survivre
c'est terrible quand on en arrive à ça
mais eux le système de santé italien est
véritablement à bout
sorte avec le nombre de cas qui augmente
imaginez vous que depuis hier on a
recensé quand même on a dépassé la barre
des quinze mille cas déclarés dont
quatre enfants
depuis le début de l'épidémie c'est
énorme
il y a des statistiques qui sont sortis
et qui disent que au niveau mondial si
vous voulez compte tenu du nombre
d'habitants en italie c'est le chiffre
le plus élevé et que la mortalité est
également la plus élevée en italie par
rapport aux autres pays touchés
toujours en fonction du nombre
d'habitants dans la péninsule
donc c'est véritablement des chiffres
qui sont peur en fonction de la
population à plus de 1200 personnes qui
ont péri dans les dernières heures ariel
on a vu arriver en italie des tonnes de
matériel médical en provenance de la
chine
est-ce que ça rassure un peu quand même
la population et coûté plus que rassuré
je crois que les italiens l'ont pris
comme un geste magnifique de grande
solidarité parce que il faut savoir
qu'au début de l'épidémie il y a quand
même un climat de méfiance et
d'abaissement qui s'était créée par
rapport à la communauté chinoise
on accusait comme dans d'autres pays
bien sûr on accusé les chinois d'être à
l'origine du mal d'avoir facilité la
propagation en italie enfin bref c'était
devenu très très compliqué les relations
et puis disons qu'avec cette décision
qui a été annoncée par le gouvernement
chinois qui a envoyé quelque chose comme
des milliers de masques chirurgicaux des
gants des lunettes de protection et même
une équipe de spécialistes en coville 19
les italiens ont été particulièrement
touché un centime en que dans un moment
très difficile de leur histoire parce
que c'est quand même la première fois
qu'il ya une telle crise sanitaire
on a véritablement le sentiment d'être
mieux au moyen âge à l'époque de la
peste noire et tout un pays placé à
l'isolément 6
les c'est quand même très inhabituel
dans ce geste de l' empire du milieu a
suscité une grande tendresse je me lance
la machine mais on souhaite que ce
matériel aide le personnel hospitalier à
venir en aide à pouvoir soigner toutes
ces personnes qui ont besoin et ont
terriblement actuellement en italie que
ça puisse contenir la crise de la coved
19 merci beaucoup ariel de nous avoir
parle on dirait que les biens seront
constitués de la situation en italie
merci à beaurevoir